ce mardi 15 mars dans cette station
service de magny les hameaux les prix
avoisinent les 2 euros le litre malgré
la facture salée pas question pour
emeline de mettre le frein à main cette
étudiante installé dans cette commune
rurale n'a pas le choix elle doit faire
le plein pour pouvoir se rendre à son
école ou à son stage on peut plus se
permettre d'aller facilement voir de la
famille des amis
sans compter les kilomètres combattants
faut que l'essence diminuent ce que ça
devient vraiment compliqué quelques
kilomètres plus loin chevreuse commune
de 5600 habitants difficile aussi de se
passer de la voiture les habitants
décidé de s'adapter à la situation et
tente de trouver des solutions chacun a
sa stratégie jeux même temps cela me
paraît nécessaire ne pas trop sortir
avec le véhicule
mais j'habite dans un coin ou ans mais
pratiquement obligé vous prendre une
voiture on essaye quand même de repérer
les endroits où l'essence est un petit
peu moins cher
on a deux voitures essence et on a une
commande d'une électrique aussi donc
voilà on en est là aujourd'hui bon le
trajet en voiture dans les communes
rurales ce gérant l'a bien remarqué
installé ici depuis sept ans il est face
à une situation inédite son nombre de
clients a été divisé par deux je n'ai
jamais vendu aussi peu vu ça c'est sûr
en temps normal j'en vends jamais beau
jeu n'ont pas beaucoup parce que je suis
toujours un petit peu plus cher que
total ou le carrefour de conair est là
depuis trois semaines j'en vois encore
moins parce que tout le monde se dit
comme il est un peu plus cher on va tous
donc là j'en vends très très peu en
première ligne face à cette flambée ses
habitants des communes rurales espèrent
désormais une baisse dans les prochaines
semaines le premier ministre jean castex
a notamment annoncé une remise à la
pompe de 15 centimes par litre de
carburant à partir du 1er avril et
pendant quatre mois